Speaker 1: The failed former president Donald
Trump exploded on his platform tro essential
after a jury found him liable for sexual assault
and defamation of Jean Carroll in that Bergdorf
Goodman department store in manhattan in the
1990s. You knew he was going to absolutely
lose his mind. Let's take a look at the various
uncontrollable posts, sort of like diarrhea of
the post rather than the mouth right before the
decision was made, Trump troth in, quote, waiting
for a jury decision on a quote on a capital F
false accusation where I, despite being a current
political candidate and leading all others in both
parties, am not allowed to speak or defend myself.
Now that's a lie. Trump could have testified. In
fact, he said he was flying back to the U.S. to
testify. His lawyers were like, No, you're not,
dude. You're not doing that. Saying even as hard
nosed reporters scream questions about this case
at me. In the meantime, the other side has a book
falsely accusing me of Capital R rape and is
working with the press. I will therefore not
speak until after the trial, but will appeal the
capital U. Unconstitutional silencing of me as a
candidate no matter the outcome. Now, remember,
while he was president, Jean Carroll wanting to
have these allegations adjudicated wasn't
fair because Trump was a sitting president.
Now that Trump is no longer a president, the
whole trial is unfair because he's a candidate.
Endless. Then we got the decision, and that's
when Trump turned on caps lock and really went
in for the crazy Trump posting. After the verdict,
quote, I have absolutely no idea who this woman
is. This verdict is a disgrace, a continuation
of the greatest witch hunt of all time. Then
trolling thing again in all capital letters. Very
unfair trial. And then the video started Trump
using troth essential almost like a short form,
like tic tac, a short form vlog platform posting
these 15 and 22nd videos. Let's take a look at the
first one here. Trump putting on his suit and tie
and standing in front of flags in order to deliver
these unhinged statements, if you can imagine.
Speaker 3: This was a very unfair trial. That's
all you have to say. This was a very unfair trial.
Speaker 1: Right. And that's the that's
the full statement from Trump in that
particular video. Then he wrote, and it's
funny. It says it's a 15 second video,
but because of like the little closing animation,
it's really only like a seven second video. Trump
then posting a 21 second video.
Speaker 3: I have absolutely no
idea who this woman is. The verdict is a
disgrace, a continuation of the greatest
witch hunt of all time. Absolutely a shame.
Speaker 1: So that's Trump reading the troth that
I mentioned to you earlier. I guess they just put
it up on the teleprompter. Maybe that's why it's
in all caps to make it easier for Trump to read. I
don't know. It's all very strange. And then Trump
putting out a slightly lengthier vlog about this.
Speaker 3: What else can you expect from a Trump
hating Clinton appointed judge who went out of
his way to make sure that the result of this
trial was as negative as it could possibly be?
Speaker 1: Now, there's no evidence that any
of this is true. Every lawyer I
spoke to this morning said that
the judge handled the case perfectly fine.
Speaker 3: Speaking to it in control of a
jury from an anti-Trump area, which
is probably the worst place in the
United States for me to get a fair trial.
Will be appealing this decision. It's a
disgrace. I don't even know who this
woman is. I have no idea who she is,
where she came from. This is another scam.
Speaker 1: I'm finding this a little difficult
to believe. To be perfectly honest with.
Speaker 3: You, it's a political witch
hunt. And somehow we're going to have to
fight this. We cannot let our country go
into this abyss. This is disgraceful. You have
somebody running for office. You have a woman
that's financed and lied about it. She totally
lied about it by Democrat operatives, like just
about the biggest one there is. And she said that
wasn't true. They found that she lied about it.
Speaker 1: Isn't this incredibly whiny?
Speaker 3: And the judge wasn't even,
I guess, letting it be put in as evidence?
Huh? The whole thing is a scam, and it's
a shame and it's a disgrace to our country.
Speaker 1: There you go. Very powerful statement
from Donald Trump. So listen, we've got Trump,
who has now been arrested and charged in New York,
found civilly liable in New York, likely to be
arrested and charged again in Georgia sometime
between. I'm trying to remember the dates
we heard from Fanny Willis down in Georgia.
I believe it was between July 11th and September
1st or something like that, where they have this
next charging period where grand jury decisions
will be made and charging decisions will be made.
This is not going very well for Donald Trump, but
I have to hand it to the MAGA people. His support
among the Republican Party is only going up. And
so it's still appears that this is very much not
good for Trump in terms of the general election,
although he still could win. Look at the polling.
It's close, but it is it is actually quite good
for Trump in the Republican primary and in some
way in some indirect way. Trump's charges and the
$5 million liability finding in all of this stuff,
it may be desantis's undoing because it's
actually boosting Trump. Now, Trump has a town
hall tonight on CNN. We're going to talk about
that later. And they damn, damn well better ask
about this stuff. But I don't I don't know that
it will. We'll get to that a little bit later.